thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a very
proper wild ride with Stevo we've got
the prop Master it's Carrot Top This
Guy's the most fascinating dude he's
like the face of Las Vegas man and dude
is this hilarious plus I totally went to
see his show in Vegas unbelievable I
really do agree he is the most
criminally underrated Show in Las Vegas
and after you watch this podcast just
like me you're gonna be dying to go see
Carrot Top perform live but maybe you're
going to be needing to take a dump well
bring here Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole with you is this amazing this
is brand new just came out Stevo's butt
wipes for your butthole these are
cooling oh man and you know what they're
going to be stocking stuffers all over
the world Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole and man when the holidays kick
in and everybody's stressing out running
late gotta get the gifts if you're
somebody who sells stuff online you
might be kind of stressed out backed up
with orders gotta get them out but we're
not gonna be worrying about it because
we use ship station we're going to be
getting Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole into every stocking consider
stocking stuffed when you work with ship
station if you're an e-commerce person
then you have to have ship station for
the holidays and guess how generous ship
station is they're going to hook you up
with two months free a two-month free
trial all you gotta do is go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo and you're off to the races with a
60-day free trial that's with all the
best rates from the big carriers like
FedEx UPS post office man it's all in
one easy to use interface you print out
your labels you slap them on and they're
gone like I swear that is how we do it
because everything that we ship from
stevo.com is with ship station like the
brand new Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole God I'm so glad I've wanted
these forever and I don't have to worry
about getting them to my customers
because online shipping is so easy with
ship station you gotta try it so one
more time go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo and make ship happen all right
let's get into this
ladies and gentlemen Carrot Top what's
happening buddy yeah let's get honestly
the last time I hopped in a random van
in a parking lot was Dr Kevorkian so um
that's why I used to come hopping into
unknown van come out of here a lot Dr
Kevorkian man he he uh is it safe to say
his crime was not killing people that
was actually just being an arrogant dude
I used one of my very first props it was
a it was a like a little rubber duck
with an extension cord it was Dr
kevorky's bathtub toy
my manager last night was uh it was
telling me dude Carrot Top is uh he gets
such a hard time he's the most
criminally underrated show in the world
yeah yeah
criminally underrated that's great yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know what's kind of
weird because I've been doing this
almost 37 years yeah I started in 1985
and for so much for the for for so long
that would give me so much [ __ ] like all
the time and then finally you know after
37 years you're like did I make the cut
did I make the club right can I go to
the barbecues now I mean I've been in
you know like I've done my time so uh
it's it's it's lessened a little bit and
I always find it shocking when people do
come to the show and the first thing
they say is wow that was that was really
good though like their shock it would be
like right right right oh man you know I
didn't want to come but it was grilling
kind of good I get that I'm sure too
right
I love that one I've always hated you I
hate comedy but you're it was good it
was It was kind of fun it was kind of
yeah it was actually pretty good it's
actually pretty good feeling good thank
God that thought it [ __ ] blue
how does that work were you touring
before and then all of a sudden you get
a Vegas residency or yeah how does that
work like you've been doing the The
Comedy Club Circuit yeah we were doing
yep we're doing that we're doing all
that doing the clubs and colleges that
was my main thing colleges I do I do two
a day
literally I do one in the morning at
like a cafeteria and literally was there
was one in a Breezeway one time I said
where's the stage I said right there I
said in the Breezeway and they said yes
I mean people like walking into their
class and you know I'm standing there
hey here's the doctor working bathtub
toy
and uh and then at night you do this big
huge Auditorium you know like you know
in Penn State right you're in this 3000
seat thing and then
you go yeah so it was crazy the college
thing really is what made me uh get out
there and The Roots You Know marketing
and then started slowly getting a little
you know a little television
um I had some 18 T commercials which
kind of funny talking about you're
talking about you getting recognized
from the podcast and I used to do these
at T commercial and they were there
everywhere they were like the
progressive ones now they're on every
eight seconds and I used to always see
people I I hate them too and I try to
make as many as I can so that at least
there's new ones to hate and um people
are coming to me in the mall like we're
in town I'd be playing at and they say
uh oh my God what are you doing what are
you doing in town yes I said I'm doing a
show and they said a show like a phone
show and I said yeah [ __ ] phone show
no it's a comedy show they only thought
that I said phones they had no idea that
it was a comic
and it was just it was really weird
there wasn't like a lot of people right
like I didn't know you were a comedian I
thought you just a sales person for ATT
so it was a whole new world of people
that would come in and see shows not
knowing that I actually had like an act
or something right and that was 18 T
commercials like in the what year like
1990s probably had a collect call you
know and one of our basic audience was
Prisoners you know that's basically what
I'm talking to you I'd say that in the
set like no who's who are we working to
prisoners or something but um right yeah
but I was lucky to have the gig you know
and then to answer your question yeah
from that you slowly get into I got um
weird how I got to Vegas I was doing
Regis and Kathie Lee of all shows and
it's you know nine o'clock in the
morning and I do this I do the show like
and I did great and I came off and this
this guy walked over and says wow that
was tremendous I've never seen you and I
said oh cool he says You must you must
kill in Vegas
and I said never played Vegas and he
says you've never played Vegas and I
said nope he says what the [ __ ] you are
Vegas and I said oh well I've never
played and he says if I book you in
Vegas would you do would you do it and I
said of course I'd do it I'm a [ __ ] I'm
a comic what do you mean when I'm doing
so the uh the guy came here and said I'm
gonna book you and it was Kathy Lee
Gifford's manager so they called Bally's
and they got me in the club of the first
time
and then I did literally Friday night I
did really well it was just a little
comedy club and the guy says hey we want
to put you in the big theater and this
is I've never I mean Vegas is different
than Penn State where there's a whole
full of kids screaming and Bong jokes
and whatever you want
you know this is Vegas and it's you know
a whole different audience and he says
we're gonna put you in the big rooms
like 3 000 seats I was terrified I mean
literally terrified and I got there and
it was
you know booths which is the killer of
Comedy really people sitting in a booth
though you want you want them sitting in
chairs you're in a booth they're gonna
fall asleep and you know eating a steak
dinner whatever the [ __ ] they do so I
bombed I mean pretty much bombed
horribly like I wanted to get out of the
business and um
I did that for a year at Bally's but in
and out bombing every night and uh
and then the MGM Grand called and said
you want to move to our room and it was
like an intimate 600 that's where David
copfield the joke of my show is I used
to play the MGM until David cop Phil had
me disappear but um literally he did he
said I want and then people like that's
funny he actually called the newspaper
or called me and said why did you say
that in the newspaper and I said what he
said I made you disappear I didn't make
I said it's a goddamn joke dude you're
you're so in a sense he made me
disappear because he wanted the room you
know you know Copperfield Carrot Top so
I I stayed there for and it was 10 years
10 years at the MGM but were you really
bombing yeah but Bally's well no or do
you think I think I was because it's
this huge room and I I was so used to
this thundersen college kids going crazy
and people in Vegas you know we just saw
a building blow up we don't really care
about your your [ __ ] cowboy boot with
a kickstand on it whatever joke I would
have so I was doing better than I
thought but it was not it was
uncomfortable painful and comfortable
and then I got to the MGM it's a little
better it's more intimate but Vegas was
still a different audience I it took me
forever to to get used to an audience in
Vegas right yeah that David Copperfield
was was going into a 600 seat theater
he's doing it now he's still in it
really yeah he does 18 shows a day I I'm
not kidding I haven't said him can you
can go for a hike do something but why
do you do five shows a day
he says why do you do one I said because
I have a life
one shows enough man yeah one show a day
yeah one show with David Sunday have one
day off Sunday yeah yeah and then I get
a week off
every uh every month so I go to Florida
and I have a house there cool man how
long do you do that for
uh how long have I done that no no yeah
I mean like is there a consistency
because like yeah four weeks on one week
off four weeks yeah on average
look my manager has a car payment so I
have to I have to keep working I can
keep working yeah you said you do a lot
of TV George Carlin by the way who got
one of my all-time you know well yeah
and I it was same room I was I was
coming in and he was coming out and um
I love this story because it's so weird
he come off stage and I was standing
there in the wings and he sees me and he
says uh hey get a kid and I say don't I
said I'm starting tomorrow no what are
you doing here as I'm starting I'm just
watching I was trying to steal some of
your act and he kind of laughed you know
I was doing my [ __ ] because you know
whatever and I said him and what do you
start I said tomorrow how many shows did
you do I said one and then I do two on
the weekends he goes what are you doing
the weekends and I made that joke I said
my manager has a car payment so I you
know and he goes oh really why the [ __ ]
do you do two shows and why do why
and I said well I figured if I if I [ __ ]
up the first one I get a second shot at
it he got all my face never give the
audience the [ __ ] up or never ever
shut your cut yourself short you do your
[ __ ] and you [ __ ] do the way you do
it they don't like it [ __ ] them and he
walked off and I was like well that went
well you know and um I looked at this
man dressed I'm gonna go and he said no
no dude he [ __ ] loves you just
staying he wouldn't he wouldn't talk to
you like that if he didn't love you and
sure enough I waited around five minutes
he said hey
brought me back in his room and we
didn't talk about anything else it's
just just life he didn't talk about that
he didn't even ask about my comedy he
just said it was a fan
he said I like that I like your [ __ ] I
had a joke he said I like that [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] is a great joke it was a it was
a a telephone
paper cups and string telephone you know
the old cup and I used to do this a long
time ago I said they did a new version
you know the updated version of the
stupid paper cups is string right this
should be one for today's world and I
have a second cup that came out for call
waiting I just have to call you back I
have another call hey yeah I'll call you
back I'm on the phone and I have like
three cups it was conference calling and
then it was it was a clear cup for
caller ID I know it's you [ __ ] I'm
looking at you pick up dude and he
[ __ ] loved it he kept saying that's
[ __ ] funny as [ __ ] I said thanks
George thank you yeah George Carlin's it
man yeah yeah and for him to you know to
give you the blessing right you know so
I always that's how I kind of going back
to what you said earlier about people
[ __ ] on me is um right at the end of
the day when they do or someone does I
always think to those moments you know I
mean some guy is in his Attic in
Nebraska saying I [ __ ] suck and then
you got George Carlin saying you're
funny [ __ ] right that's how you keep
that's how you keep your sanity and I've
been in the same boat you know like I
got into stand up people aren't rooting
for me to kill it Steve I was doing
stand up huh like it kind of rolled
their eyes and and I have a little bit
of a George Carlin moment myself uh with
my new show
the opening scene because I've got
multimedia yeah and I got like Bill Burr
in it I love building it's just like a
hat that he kind of like it's so
symbolic to have him that the opening
sequence is me uh dangling from a rope
ladder you know from a helicopter like
getting all flown around and I drop onto
the roof of the moving tour bus and and
Bill Burr's a helicopter pilot so oh he
really is though and the thing he is
yeah in real life he's helicopter pilot
and we filmed insert shots to cut two of
him flying the helicopter so that it it
appears to be him flying me around
crashing me and oh that's great that's
right and just the it's so symbolic for
him to get behind me and sign off on me
like give me his Blessing like the way
George Carlin did yeah Billboard's
brilliant in fact
not only Bill Burr's story was I was I
went on Howard Stern and I was again
terrified hey man sometimes life is
scary and the good news is that this
episode is brought to you by better Help
Therapy online man when you get scared
it's good to talk about it it's
important to talk about it it's crucial
to talk about it and having a therapist
is the way to go I'm so glad that I have
my therapist I just had this really
important session with them because I
was uh really sad about something
something that I didn't want to talk to
like a lot of people about private stuff
you know and I got my therapist and I
felt a lot better after I talk to him I
really think that it can help you can
help everybody you want to take care of
your your mind your feelings just like
you take care of your car or your body
are going to work out at the gym why not
why don't you keep yourself in Fitness
your emotional mental Fitness and the
way to do it is with
betterhelp.com that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Stevo and this is
where you get the most convenient
accessible affordable and quality
therapy with no driving no like waiting
rooms no like no nothing just the easy
easy accessible convenient quality
affordable therapy and if you go to
betterhelp.com Stevo then you get 10 off
your first month really helps me I think
it can really help you so one one more
time go to
betterhelp.com
Stevo and that's going to help you when
you're scared let's hear about Carrot
Top at Howard Stern you know they sit in
this little out room outside you
probably maybe I've done yeah right so
you sit in the room and then they talk
about you before they bring you in right
right and you sit there and and you're
just me and my publicist and he's just
going on and on and on and you know care
you know thing and you're like oh God
okay bring them in yeah it can go either
way yeah and I walked in he says a
Carrot Top and I said how's it going he
goes you're you're like a normal guy and
I said what do you think he said I got
to be honest I don't know I thought
you're some [ __ ] weird freak dude I
mean I'm afraid dude but yeah but you
know it could have been more love and so
we're it's going great and he says do
you know do you know who Bill Burr is
and I said uh
no he says really play the bill I
haven't it's great play The Bill Burr
thing
so it's Bill Burr just [ __ ] going
coals on me I mean just right I mean
just bad and then it ends and he goes so
you don't know Bill and I said well I I
guess I probably you know I don't think
I want to meet him now like it was just
it was horrible and then when I finally
meet him he was like dude I'm so sorry
like he came and hugged me and said I
was just [ __ ] you know comic to come
he's [ __ ] around but I love you and
he he did he came to the show he's been
we're great friends now right but but it
was it was it was horrifying when he
played the tape I'm like okay yeah when
I first started doing stand up uh Dane
Cook was like a mentor to me we would um
like go out to the comedy clubs and and
you know he would do his set then I
would do my set and then we would sit
down he would give me notes but he would
do his set and then I would do my set
and or everybody's Versa and he would
just be the most vicious like terrible
like meanest like he would just reduce
use me to like the size of a thimble and
and then like bring me on stage you know
you know like and and even it was it was
so weird like it's with love yeah you
know yeah crazy so the first time you
and I met was uh at the TV show yeah a
good memory yes it was yeah you had you
had to do there's alligators in it in a
pool that sounds right yeah we got
enough and a kitty pool full of
alligators and got my butt cheek bitten
by a little Universal it didn't happen
and everyone was freaking out and you
said trust me it'll happen
but I remember backstage was going what
if what if they don't what if they don't
bite his butt we have no bit and then
you came in like dude they're going to
buy my bags fine yeah and they did it
was good
was Mel Gibson there that day it wasn't
yeah yeah and it killed you're right I
came out like yeah I did I came out in a
kilt with the with that turned into
pants it was like a prop and then I had
these stupid little legs so I had to
kill and then I went I made this stuff
for guys like me and it matched you know
the thing and then yeah and then it was
you me and Mel Gibson yeah on the lineup
now was that at the point when you were
like
bodybuilder man no I don't think so I'm
actually not if you see me in person I
have like normal size people always
think I'm bigger than it right right TV
has 10 pounds kind of thing right that's
why I just wanted to be in porn
thank you yeah I remember like you you
aren't as big as you once were is that
fair to say yeah yeah yeah
um but uh but yeah that that was great
and then there was another time we hung
out in Vegas we got this iconic photo
yes it's great
um it Booth had some like big crazy
nightclub felt like we were at a rave
yeah it probably was a rave yeah and if
we were in this big booth
you me Chris Angel Angel flavorful
Flavor Flav
and uh Tom Green yeah the five of us and
then in that photo it's a great shot
it's a really great shot how the [ __ ]
did that happen how do you guys get
together in that shot it was such a
great shot and like man did people poop
on it
was like they're like yeah Flavor Flav
Chris Angel Carrot Top Tom Green and
Stevo if that's not the Mount Rushmore
I loved it though I loved it it was such
a fun it was a fun game yeah it was fun
it was just a eclectic Gathering yeah
they're also nice flavor just came to my
show a couple weeks ago he's always been
did flavors he's like the one for
president you know when when he when he
comes to show when I announce him I said
different flavor flaves here they The
Crowd Goes ape [ __ ] yeah I mean and then
I'm like you know back to me [ __ ]
Jesus but it's crazy yeah I got him on a
plane one time I was running literally
running San Francisco Airport to my gate
and I get to the gate and this guy's
like
just
you know I'm not drunk man you got to
let me on this [ __ ] plane I'm not Dr
I'm not drunk and I look back and it's
you know see the clock has got to be
it's even flavor flavor one of the 33
flavors and I look and I said I said
flavor
he looks over he's like and I had never
met him he says carrots up I said what's
wrong why won't they let you in the
plane the lady's like excuse me sir he's
he's intoxicating he can't get on the
plane I said he's not he's not he's
intoxicated he's Flavor Flav
and I don't remember saying that and she
said sorry I said he's that's him that's
who he is he's not drunk I promise he's
I'll I'll test for it so I said give me
your hand and I walked him on the plane
let him go on and same thing to this day
he always says man you [ __ ] saved my
life man got me in the plane and he got
on the plane I mean the place was the
plane went nuts I mean he walked in the
plane
at halftime at Super Bowl crazy yeah
he's the sweetest we uh we we had him on
the podcast and um he exchanged numbers
that day and he'll just call to check on
me oh that's nice he's just I will never
do that for you
yeah what I thought was fascinating
about Flavor Flav was he is uh he went
to school for culinary so he he can cook
that's crazy and I would never have
thought that he had a chicken place here
for a while yeah he did yeah I don't
know he did and and man when we went to
go do the podcast because we don't
always do it on this tour bus normally
it's in uh like a a little Sprinter van
type thing yeah and what Drive I saw
that on the thing yeah yeah we'll drive
it over to wherever people want to meet
up for Flavor Flav it was uh this insane
mansion in Bel Air I'm like
flavor flavor you live in this
this day and yeah he's he's doing very
well for himself it's great
um
yeah dude the uh
Vegas is such um
a mystery to me you know like I was with
my tour
I uh girl and I've looked very very
happy with how
successful I've become touring you know
I I did comedy clubs for 11 years and
now I've graduated to theaters and I go
around on this tour bus with my buddies
and it's just like we're in this fun pad
making awesome videos and it just
magically teleports itself to where I
have to work for like an hour or two a
night beautiful it's it's wonderful but
but Vegas is like a market
that that I struggle with and I don't
understand it you know like well I was
saying it earlier than the thing about
Vegas is back when I first started it's
a different it's a whole different I
don't know what it is it's a whole
different
um like what thing I don't know I mean
you know when you promote this show it's
like
people
are here from this we're out so you know
like what I don't know Carl used to say
that he says you know half the people
you know that couldn't get into oh came
to you know
and I mean sometimes you think that's
true because they'll say yeah Blue Man's
sold out [ __ ] we'll go see orange man so
uh orange and blue man but currently she
said he said yeah
they can't get there because you
sometimes wonder like that because I
mean I've got a fan base now so I think
I think there's a fan base that's right
particularly there for me but I bet you
this I'm always afraid to ask you know
because I don't know how many people
that first time right here
um
but uh there probably is a lot of people
that have never seen the show have no
idea what the [ __ ] the character I
mean I've had that before too right what
do you sing and I said what do I sing
you know and you change your show up
like constantly never have never added
one new joke in 35 years
I'm still doing Nixon things it's great
The Kills which is surprising no I try
to keep it fresh I miss my I really
pride myself in that I mean almost every
day there's something whether it's a
prop right it's in one liner or it's a
video you know clip I'm trying to think
of something now but baseball because
baseball sure
they're wearing mittens
the guys on first base he's got like
mittens on like actual like cooking
[ __ ] mittens
and I'm I there's all these things I
talk about sports and we're losing our
what happened to you know getting such a
quarterback now I need to you know right
they tripped him that he tripped I mean
are you tripping I said it's [ __ ]
football tackling right
so the Mitten thing makes me laugh
because I have a video this guy with his
mittens but I'm gonna put Martha
Stewart's face over it so it looks like
Martha Stewart's gonna still second
because she's got the cooking mittens on
it right that's great that's one of my
guy that's here is now just heard that
he's like [ __ ] now I gotta make that so
Ah that's great do you have a creative
process like that every morning if you
you know you got a show to do like do
you wake up at a certain time every day
do you you know okay I gotta right here
get some ideas I never ever have done
that I've never never I'm not structured
at all like that I've never said I'm
gonna ride I mean one day I I have a
whole bit in my show where I talk about
I was determined to write a joke but um
usually I just I just freely I just kind
of I'll go to lunch or I'll go somewhere
I was on a plane last night for eight
hours
I'll come up with something you know
like we landed you know we waited on the
tarmac for an hour because our gate
wasn't ready did they did they not know
we were coming like their Gate's not
ready are they building a new gate where
so
and I looked up the thing there's 92
gates at the airport but there's not one
[ __ ] gate that they could put us at
so we just sat out there you know yeah I
got a restaurant they say your table's
not ready you'd like to sit at the bar
and have a drink while you would get
your table ready but you're not sitting
at a bar you're sitting on a [ __ ]
tarmac waiting for your [ __ ] gate so
it's a little different and they know
we're coming right we left Orlando they
know we're on our way right the uh my
manager when as he was saying about how
you're criminally underrated he said
that you have a workshop where like
something children working there by the
way around underage children to make
iPhones
I mean you did uh come up
it's a switch up yeah I know but there
is a there's a big Warehouse across the
street in fact Paulie Shore just visited
it uh not long ago we had a great time
filming a little bit he's trying to take
over my gig in Vegas right and yeah we
gotta ask him ask him about that yeah
he's like he's punishing him to go man
he's been here too long yeah it's uh
it's pretty incredible the um reputation
that Paulie Shore has in in the comedy
world like comedy clubs will have
um like a condo or sorry when the when
the comedian comes you stay in this
special apartment that they've got for
for their their Headliners and these
these condos are notoriously
they're known for being sort of a
splattered
I've saved a few of them myself you've
been rolling around
it wasn't many years I I would say I'm
gonna take all the money that I made and
I'm staying in a hotel yeah in the
comedy condo yeah because you don't want
to roll around and polish or seeds no no
no no I mean not not every night you
know
yeah I don't really care to roll around
in anybody's seed except my own you know
that's how it is and I do like to blast
my seed all over the place with a raging
hard boner that's how I like to do it
that's how my girl likes me to do it
with a raging hard boner and you know
what helps with a raging hard boner
Bluetooth tablets if you haven't tried
them yet then I think you might be out
of your mind especially if you're
wondering taking Bluetooth tablets might
be a lot of fun yeah it is a lot of fun
it's got the same active ingredient as
both Viagra and Cialis except it only
costs a fraction of the of the price
plus if you go to bluetooth.com and use
the promo code Stevo they'll give you an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets completely for free all you have
to pay is five bucks for shipping plus
with the medical provider at
bluetooth.com you don't have to go to an
awkward doctor's office no like don't
nothing it's super simple you get your
prescription right there in a couple
minutes online and the Bluetooth tablets
are on the way it only costs you five
bucks for shipping to get an entire
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets
absolutely for free so there's nothing
to lose here you can satisfy your
curiosity for how much fun you're gonna
have with Bluetooth tablets and the
Raging hard boner they're gonna give you
hey man I love it I think you're gonna
love it too so one more time go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo to get that amazing deal you're
gonna thank me and so will your wiener
yeah all right let's get back to it
it's so great man
um
so uh the the writing process I don't
know how you guys get the comic but I
don't do you do that before whatever
right I might just it'll just it'll hit
me yeah I mean I try it and I don't for
sure try it out on anybody like this is
funny and I [ __ ] do it I've eat [ __ ]
it goes out yeah you Workshop it is
really the way and and for me what
what's happened is that my worlds have
converged so I'll uh decide like what I
want
um like a tent pole of my hour to be and
it'll be like like an outrageous
done and then like the process of
putting that stunt together and
executing it and it will will become a
bit in the show well that's great that's
what I have now it's called The Bucket
List tour yeah I saw that and uh like
you know like one of the things that
that I had I was like I want to go
skydiving butt naked with another man
strapped to my back and furiously
masturbate so that I actually ejaculate
simultaneously as I'm falling out of the
airplane
and I pulled it off
[Music]
yeah I pulled it
that's it I I consider it the crown
jewel of my career oh man I love it yeah
and then you know there's [ __ ] sorry
Denny's yeah
there's one where I got a medical
professional in Disguise administering
stolen general anesthesia drugs into my
arm while I'm riding a bicycle
yeah see it's a different kind of Comedy
you know I love it it's a little
different kind of comic yeah I mean
after it's been much the same I think
after each bit I play the play the video
so there's like video breaks oh that's
cool yeah yeah and uh it's fun because a
lot of comedians will make up stories
that aren't even true yeah you know
Outlander stories that are that are keep
it all real yeah the whole Show's and
I'll keep saying it over and over to the
this you can't make this is true and
then I wonder if they really think it's
true but it is you might embellished a
little bit yeah yeah no I I stick to
every little detail and then the video
matches up to the details it's great
um we had an interesting guy in the in
the van yesterday I just thought about
that that guy Pierce oh yeah
no no I was trying to figure that out
like uh yeah you wanna do you want to
talk about it now and lay down the story
because I I had some questions about
that but I still wanted to ask the guy
well I mean there's a guy who came to my
attention I received a
video via direct message from my buddy
Eric Andre who is a just an absolute
lunatic and the video was of um
it's like a bathroom doorway and you're
looking at you know nothing and then
this body but this guy jumps in and you
see that it's his butt and actually like
the whole in the crack and then
unbelievably out of the guy's butthole
come his testicles he poops his own
balls out of his own butt and they drop
I used to do this
you stole that for me it's maybe it's
Peril thinking maybe he didn't directly
steal it for me but it was crazy
all right
well it's crazy because he's married
with kids right he has a wife of course
he does but I wonder but I wanted to
show somebody and then and so I typed in
his name and all this gay porn stuff
came up and I was like
This Guy's in the gay porn and then when
we asked him about it he was like I'm
not gay and we were like you do you do
gay porn he's like I'm an actor
and nobody nobody called them on it but
he's like yeah of course I do I'm an
actor
he's like no no I'm married with kids
I'll let you do gay porn yeah but only
when they say action
so it's different right
and we kind of just glossed over that
note I mean yeah he he felt in the
details he said that um I said because I
picture like if you're not gay and
you're in gay porn then maybe you're
just on the receiving end and I would
like uh some but he said no there's uh
he's like [ __ ] no dude
yeah defensive no man I dig chicks when
I didn't mean
but uh he described this uh this special
drug which uh it it he it thickens your
blood it's an injection of something
that starts with a T yeah that uh it's
like it thickens your blood and makes
you hard as a rock for like four to six
hours you can go completely nuts and
that's how that's that's how he's able
he just [ __ ] dudes all day which is
cool but then he goes back to his wife
where he's like madly in love with her
nine [ __ ] oh that's a slow day yeah is
that yeah and and the greatest guy too
yeah he was super cool and and that
would be an interesting podcast but I've
I totally forgot about until we started
talking about it yeah like I love that
though he's no I'm not gay I'm actually
he was like I'm an actor you're like he
shook his head like he was like why are
you guys asking that like no dude I'm an
actor like what are you talking about
it's so great you can see it just
happens
um did you see that I think it was a
Steve Carell movie Abracadabra was that
with Jim Carrey and Steve Carell it was
dear it was really funny it was at a
residency in Vegas Jim Carrey was like a
parody of uh Chris Angel it was a yeah
Jim Carrey was a parody of uh of Chris
Angel right and Steve Corral was a
parody of David Copperfield were you in
that movie no but I saw it I remember
seeing it they didn't have anybody I
didn't think they had a they didn't have
a Carrot Top Cameo that's right yeah
that's [ __ ] I mean is that how like
a residency is like like do you have a
penthouse on the top floor of the hotel
and then you go down and do shows or
it's kind of like you do your own thing
no is Wayne new people always think that
though yeah they go oh like Elvis I just
saw the elephants they have the old days
and that thing and you sweets there's
broads and Coke and no there's stuff
there's there's ESPN at home
and
since you started doing a residency like
you kind of just been here and when I
first got the room at the Luxor I was up
at the top of the you know there's a big
Suite up there at the top what happens
up there oh well
a horribleness because you have to take
the side elevator because like this up
the side it's called an inclinator
really yeah so it moves sideways so it
with you when you're when you're drunk
you don't feel a thing When You're Sober
like what the [ __ ] and so you go and you
stop at every floor and everybody you
know the time you get to your room
everyone's you know
inclinator is that realmator yeah the
inclinator and so it was yeah it was
horrible living up there it's you know
you have to just live with the you know
right and so uh yeah you get you know
now you get on and go home and you're
living all my life and yeah you're at
the top floor of that
in that little light you sit that's you
your car was sleeping because the
[ __ ] lights on all mine
no it's right below it this is the one I
remember when the Luxor was built it was
in the 90s yeah like um and it was it
was maybe it was like the first Billion
Dollar Casino hours to create some
staggering number and I remember
thinking God it seems that it seems kind
of evident that the odds are not
actually in the favor of the gamblers
you know because like how are they
building have each new casino bigger and
more like yeah they made their money
back that way like they're made they're
they're
they seem to be like trying their best
to let you know because everything that
they put up is just more fantastic and
expensive than the last and nobody gets
the message
nobody gets the message where's this
money coming from everybody comes to
Vegas they're just making donations
it's coming from you are you do you
gamble much or no did you when you first
got here never yeah not really never
it's weird never I remember when I'm
fascinated by the whole uh it's a weird
energy it's weird energy and I don't
know the I don't know the the math and
the numbers and I know like you said you
know look at the size of your house look
at the size 16 and someone's getting
[ __ ] you know yeah so I don't know
like smoke and I don't like a lot of
crowds yeah so I just don't I don't
that's not my thing right I I worked on
cruise ships I shouldn't say that I love
that I love it
I worked on cruise ships as a circus
clown before you know the the TV stuff
started and um
the cruise ship director they would have
an orientation show in the first night
of the week-long cruise and at the end
of the show it says to everybody now
have a have a great time make sure you
stop in the casino make a donation and
uh like it it was it was good good fun
and uh
and I just think it's it's so perplexing
to me and I think that you don't have to
worry about saying oh I love Vegas
because like like gambling is just a
real thing you know like here in Vegas I
I remember like learning a lot of these
uh dealers like the Blackjack like
whatever you know like they're running
the table when their shift ends a lot of
them just hop over to the other side of
the table
like that yeah yeah you would think that
the people working in the casino yeah
you would think that these people
working in the casino would be most uh
educated about like
about what's going on yeah what's going
on the inside they would have the
Insight right like to however they're so
close to it they're so educated they
know what's going on they get done work
how this works and then they just go to
the other side of the table and make a
donation they donate everything that's
nothing I hated about too and I said
never but the two or three times I ever
did you know I'm sitting there and I'm
I'm looking at it whatever I don't know
I don't know what to do it's like you
know look at the dealer and she's like
so I'm like like hit or and again this
was like what the [ __ ] there's so much
pressure right so I just follow her and
nine times out of ten I would I would
win just usually then they get it wrong
too sometimes but people would get so
mad you just ruined like I'd go you know
hit me and the guy she's like Jesus
[ __ ] ruin the whole thing and I said
how he's like and he just get mad and
leave and I said what did I do she said
you did nothing you're supposed to hit
that I said but why do you just [ __ ]
explain me
was I not supposed to hit it she goes no
you're supposed to hit it he's got
pissed that he didn't he took his card
because his card is my goddamn car
because I got the card yeah yeah like I
sit down on the table I probably did
[ __ ] up the game no but that's it like
the gamblers are just so weird
superstitious it's like I've tried to
play like Texas Hold'em at a Commerce
Casino and then you go and sit down and
people are pissed that you like hit
they're like dude you're not what are
you doing right nobody has any [ __ ]
idea what they're doing you know like
it's all luck yeah and that's the thing
that like like what alcoholic like will
justify as like drinking like a gambler
is like dude there's uh you know there's
strategy involved in this
I mean you get the poker championships
right poker like the like there's people
who are like good at it right yeah
yeah that's a valid argument I have
nothing to rebute that with but yeah I
was one of the two I mean the same thing
I mean these people say they're really
good at it but are they or is it just
luck is it I I don't know because
there's always the Championships in the
same guy like Jesus and those other guys
they're always they're always in the
Phil Hellmuth or like
famous for making a bunch of money
playing poker and they like beat out
like 25 000 people of like you know to
get to that table so it's like I
remember when uh when I was uh 20 years
old I had just gotten out of my first
rehab
and uh I was living with a guy worked
with in a restaurant
and they would have like poker night and
and I'd be trying to party and like you
know like
because I was you know because you're a
drinker
degenerate right you know like the rehab
didn't stick you know so I was trying to
do my thing and get loaded and hammered
and these guys were playing poker like
all night until the sun came up and I
was just like when are you guys gonna
stop with this poker and party with me
you know this is so annoying like stop
it there's like 12 hours after you got
out of rehab
right and uh and I just remember like
that feeling that there was a a a really
genuinely addictive quality of this they
could not stop the sun's coming up it
was like they were on cocaine yeah they
were just playing poker pot calling the
kettle bleed like you just got out of
like you [ __ ] you guys have a problem
dude right right right
I get it but uh but but there's just
like so that was one of the one of the
you know did I just said gambling always
just weirded me out and my mother's
father my my maternal grandfather
uh was like during World War II I think
it was he uh
sold bootleg gasoline and in uh Canada
because because of the war they had
rations you could only buy so much
gasoline even if you were rich but he
was this kind of a shady character who
wouldn't sell bootleg gasoline beyond
the rations you could get as much as you
wanted from him and that made him quite
a wealthy man he uh like had a boat he
walked around notoriously with like a
big wad of cash and it's very like
flashy kind of a shady character
alcoholic and um got wealthy but he had
a gambling problem and all this money
that he made selling bootleg gasoline he
gambled it away and then he shot his
shot himself suicide
gunshot to the head with some uh
got a gun I got gunshot that you know
and then so like and that happened when
I was I mean I think I was a newborn
baby I never even met the guy I don't
know but but that was another like
there's all these things with gambling
like I've never been into it yeah never
played a bet in my life except when I
got uh paid a fairly obnoxious amount of
money to uh promote
I have some gambling app right yeah then
and I did I did that it's interesting
your grandfather shot himself in the
head they said when men can commit
suicide they'll shoot their brains out
and then when women do it they'll either
like take pills or shoot themselves in
the heart because they don't want
anybody messing up their face right
isn't that a weird stat it's really
crazy man it's true guys are just like
[ __ ] it yeah you hold this you know I
mean that was like a Debbie Downer of a
yeah thank you for getting good suicide
jokes
I was in a place in L.A one time and
these ladies were like a little diner
and these ladies were looking at the
cover People magazine and share was on
the cover and they kept going on and on
they're like oh my god look how
beautiful Cher still looks look at that
and I took everything not so I said you
know that's been
photoshopped but still even if it even
if right the [ __ ] dude it's wild is that
even if it was the Photoshop look how
great she looks
is it true that like Texas banned uh yes
that's true well it was something
they bailed filters on some phone
because kids are making themselves look
you know better and then they meet
people and they're not the skin isn't
fear and they're welcome to every dating
app welcome to the world welcome to the
world I think you could tell you look at
someone's picture if it's been filtered
or Not Jesus or they're like taking a
selfie and you don't see their stomach
like you get there when did this come
out like two days ago or something like
that yeah yeah they have that in your
acting no not yeah but it will be
probably it's pretty I mean I'll do the
I'll do that my joke will be something
about really here's me here's picture
meat filter not filter it'd be something
like that yeah picture of me with the
filter I mean because they see these you
know the Kardashians the like they're
like oh my God these women are perfect
and it's just like an unrealistic
expectation and so I think you know even
communicating with like people people in
real life on an app like they don't look
like that like people that you
communicate like half of them don't look
like that at all I do a Juke in the show
I said you know people I love people
when they talk about [ __ ] in me that
it's you know like carrots have said
facelifts and I [ __ ] a face when I look
better if out of Facebook number one
secondly it's this is a picture of me
two years ago and my picture comes up
it's just me this is me now and it's a
picture of Caitlyn Jenner and I said
nothing it's the same [ __ ] and it
[ __ ] kills every night and this me
now two years this is me now the [ __ ]
whatever you know everybody's like this
it's the same thing so how long how may
I make that instead of the face stuff
say you know filters yeah I don't filter
this is me filter this is me unfiltered
it's about the same joke right the uh
as I said that you've got a video wallet
at your show yeah that's that how long
have you had that it used to not be a
video yeah no I used to just be a it
would just be a it's not a whole like we
do we have we shoot up stuff we don't
have like probably you have the uh you
know really nice wall which is a
projection kind of thing but it's in a
big trust with lights and stuff but for
years and years and years and years I
would just have my logo on it behind me
you know like just carrotub right and my
lighting guy one night says uh why don't
you utilize that big screen for for like
jokes what are you talking about and I
think the first joke was it was a
picture of Michael Jackson and and I'd
say got your nose and it you know take a
thing and the nose would go away and so
then it created a month now I have I
think I have 500 over 500
uh joke picture jokes yeah that kind of
the Kardashian that kind of yeah boom
here's Biden joking boom but trump it
just so it goes into it's it's a quick
but it's fun because there's another way
to present a joke with opposed to proper
thank God
how about impressions are there like uh
dude
get into no I don't do it because I'm
trying to do one right now I can't do
anything like a trump one I mean my
trump is just horrible no I think about
you know Stella I can't I can't do Trump
still you know I think my first
impression I think I used to do Jimmy
Carter when I was a kid my mom would
have bridge then she'd come in and wake
me up with all of her Bridge friends see
do you Jimmy Carter what the [ __ ] it's
you know it's midnight I'm like yeah
and my mom was like how [ __ ] great is
that who can do Jimmy Carter
I met Jimmy Carter and I told him that
story and he said well that's great
that's that's great so that's great son
you know Bozeman Montana I was getting
uh I was getting this is great I was
getting up I was getting by myself
before I had people to help me with my
so I pulled up like six in the morning
still dark out
and I go to open the back of my truck to
get my prop trunks out and this goddamn
Jeep comes up right like right behind me
where I'm like the [ __ ] like [ __ ]
like I'm trying to get my I have no room
to get my like I just this shot looked
back like the [ __ ] and it's
I see Jimmy Carter I don't know in the
passenger seat and then I see Ted
Turner's driving the jeep naturally
[ __ ] [ __ ] ran me over and then I
look and I said oh my God that's [ __ ]
the president and he gets out and I've
got my prop trunk and my hair was out to
this big and then Roslyn Carter gets out
and then Jane Fonda gets out and I'm
like this is way before his cell phones
I was like oh my God so I'm like Mr
President he's like oh yes I said oh my
God I used to do what are you doing here
whatever long story short Ted Turner
says get away from the [ __ ] present
basically and I said I have a show on on
Cartoon Network he said never heard of
it I said it's called am it's called am
am Mayhem it's on your it's on your
Channel
didn't care yeah that would kill me but
it's cool right Jimmy Carter just
standing there you know let's go it's
crazy he's still alive too still alive
building houses isn't that crazy you
think he's I mean he's probably just
when he's on camera he's just the
Hammers are nailed then he goes back and
I'm sure yeah but do you have anybody
that ever like comes to the audience
then and now that you're like kind of
nervous about or you know the band Queen
who came it was pretty fun really that's
pretty cool and they also did they tell
you that they're there before they got
there when you're yeah they usually tell
me before there's you know Queen's
coming like the Queens come they go no
Queen
um I thought the queen was yeah like the
queen but it was better you know and
they were so we've become best friends
now they're really sweet people but yeah
you get people you get sure I mean
Shania Twain to get the people the Toby
Keith and people come I don't know that
it's really a question of being like
nervous but I just excited wait I just
love it I love it like when the stakes
are a little higher for the performance
because there's someone that whose
opinion really matters to you you know
like it's like wow like you're so much
more like I do a better show because the
Queen's there you know like they you
know and then they win them over it's
good yeah and and then like conversely
if when someone important is there
there's people acting up with like
heckling and you know whatever like this
do you ever have a a one that you were
like like were more nervous that you
performed in front of
um
like not like nervous like you're gonna
bomb but like oh [ __ ] like I I was
nervous for him on when his dad showed
up to the show when we had to show him
he's gonna watch me jack off falling out
of an airplane
yeah he came over to me and I was like
looking at Steve how he handled that
when it was going on and he was just
like he he like he just had a little
laugh to him oh my God I have a Beyonce
and uh his sister was there like on my
fiance's family members at all various
times have have come to see my show
that's great and uh after without fail
I've gone up to each Huntington I'm
sorry sir are we still cool
we still good we're still good we're
still cool
it's our mom sorry Dad sorry Dad he was
uh I was in The Tonight Show and uh Dick
Cheney was was a guest before me and I
had literally like four Dick Cheney
props like because he'd just been all
incidentally with the shot was one of
them a shot cut one was a shotgun with
the shotgun that curved
and uh I had the game uh one of the the
game emergency where you you ain't you
try to pull the little bone out
because he had so many surgeries this is
the Dick Cheney emergency so I had a
shotgun
it was it was like two other ones and so
I'm in rehearsal you know great and and
then you know Jay says uh like you know
they can't be here you know I said well
I know that's why I made these props I
mean [ __ ] it can't be more current
and he said I said but is he going to be
is he going to stay for me or is he
going to leave he's just he's probably
gonna leave that this is the Secret
Service doesn't leave a horrible jail
and impression
pretty well Jim McCarter
um so Jay says to me what would you what
would you rather would you rather him
stay or go and I said well what do you
think he sits up to you I said well I'm
gonna get way more play if he stays
because the camera will go to him and me
and right we're gonna be really
uncomfortable on making fun of him
with him right [ __ ] there and so Jay
said let me talk to him and so he comes
up and they came up whispered he
whispered over and said you want to
State The Carrot Top and he said okay
what's a Carrot Top and so they produced
came back said okay Cheney's in he's
staying I said oh [ __ ] oh now I go [ __ ]
now I'm a little nervous so I come out
in a boom and I go hey Mr Cheney could
see you I said that's weird you're here
look I just found your gun you know
it's slayed but it was like a weird it
was like you know the crowd didn't and
the camera would come to him yeah yeah I
wonder like
did he handle it well like no I sat down
he said that was really clever funny
stuff and then and then here's where it
gets interesting so so I did like four
teeny jokes and of course I did whatever
10 other 15 jokes one was a mouse trap
to catch gay mice and it's a mouse trap
with a mirror ball on it the mirror ball
spins and I said this is a gay mouse
trap you know if you want to have a gay
rat problem you'll catch it and it's it
kills and he plays Like a Lady Gaga song
with it and so um
I did that kills I think I ended on that
one sit down it changes the evidence
that was really interesting stuff and he
shook my hand I said I looked over Jay
he's like good job and then we go to
thing and the producer walks over and
says oh my God
is it Liz Cheney yeah his wife
no Li the the the the the is there is
a gay guy uh okay the one that's on The
View or was uh yeah
she's gay though right oh yeah yeah so
anyway she was there I guess and she was
livid
I mean livid livid
not about her dad jokes because I did a
gay you know it wasn't a gay bash it was
silly right but she was like God how
dare you put that on [ __ ] television
I could hear about your screen and I
thought she was mad about the Dick
Cheney's jokes and then she goes no it's
about the key thing I said oh give him
[ __ ] off right right so yeah but but but
I I went back afterwards and I said I
said can I take a picture with him and
he said you know took a picture with him
he was nice
with the daughter but yeah yeah right of
course not was that during uh his
presidency like when he was with IEP
every time I think about him I think of
uh the guy who played him in Cheney oh
man
I really did yeah they really did it
really did good job at that it was a
Christian Bale Christian Bale really
good man you don't by any chance do
shows on Monday do you yeah can I come
see your show tonight yeah [ __ ] yeah
Audrey I would love that yeah I'd love
to have you yeah let's do it are you
getting nervous I was gonna say I was
gonna try to walk through this one but
now I'm nervous
man like uh I remember when I get off
for a week so it'll be fun it'll be a
fun one to get back into the you know
get my feet wet because you know when
I'm off for a week oh my God okay I mean
I get it man our last last night was our
first show you that'd be so much fun oh
you guys are welcome be great yeah that
that'd be really cool because it just
like talking with you uh
I mean well we got to do before Pauly
Shore takes over yeah because he's gonna
want you to go see his show tonight oh
wait he doesn't have a show tonight
uh he might have a show somewhere you
know he works hard what uh dude what a
treat man what a what a pleasure it's
been dude like here you're like like I
mean you're you dude we're both pretty
good at it I think right on appreciate
it thank God damn can't wait to see her
show tonight and and when I put this out
like uh it's always right before I put
it out that I do an insurance so
I'll have my own uh informed uh uh
opinion the the how uh criminally
underrated yeah that's not going to be a
second hand right uh second hand it'll
be you'll see well I witness to myself
it's [ __ ]
people are right yeah dude I can't wait
and uh I call you Scott yeah yeah Scott
okay good weather he's got yeah we got
two Scots a lot of Scots in Vegas well
great Scott man let's uh like let's hang
out tonight dude thank you for doing
something is there anything that we can
promote yeah besides we're at the Luxor
I think uh right yeah we got some Road
dates that are coming next year do you
do a social media like uh yeah carotop
live is my Instagram
yeah Carrot Top live just Instagram and
then yeah at real Carrot Top is I think
the others I gotta believe that your
Instagram is just never boring I think
it's fun I try to keep it light you know
just silly like masturbating on an
airplane
[ __ ] out his testicles I'm telling
you that guy sold that for me
I did that 92 I think yeah
yeah I'm gonna uh yeah I can't wait I
look forward to it thank you Scott yeah
yeah thank you very much yeah cheers
pleasure to meet you yeah good though
thanks for listening man did you think
you were gonna enjoy Carrot Top that
much like I thought it would be
fascinating but man love that dude love
that dude and I love you too and I
wasn't kidding about Stevo's butt wipes
for your butthole man is I think I'm
really onto something with this I think
we've found a hit Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole
they are available at stevo.com don't
wait to get on that man
your butthole deserves it yeah
thanks dudes